leute was geht ab hier ist euer marx und
herzlich willkommen zu der revanche wir
werden wieder das ghetto
wann wird es sind ja wir werden wieder
das ghetto investoren machen und ich
würde sagen wir spielen am anfang
schere stein papier schere stein papier
schere stein papier was wissen wir
welche ich hätte gerne lsd und schnee
noch punkte dazu dann bist du bereit
es geht los mit der einer großen sache
also auch weiter gefallen
1000 wäre schön wenn wir wieder zu mir
kommst du ja ja ja 55 war ja ja ja ich
bin gespannt leute also letztes mal
hatte ich ja meine erinnerung nach mehr
coins gehabt es kann gut sein so auf
extra herz unter wasser gesetzt
ja aber dann ich hatte einen großen
fehler gemacht natürlich habe ich auf
dem boden ich darf mit seiner jena ich
hab ich jetzt halt nicht drauf bekommen
dann kauf ich mir halt irgendwie 30
level oder so und dann gebe ich mich
damit zufrieden großer fehler wird mir
heute nicht wieder passieren
ich bin überhaupt würde ich sagen also
ein bisschen vertrauter sag mal wie man
jetzt komplett bands bzw sich
vorbereitet was ich trainiert hätte aber
so aber halt vom normalen zocken hab ich
immer so ein bisschen auf ok ich bin
sehr gespannt was ergeben wird dir bist
du bist ein bisschen aufholen
ich hätte natürlich auch gern im netz
als ich habe noch viel mehr als wie sie
erst vier kannst mir aber
sagen wir mal so du hast du dir auch
gewünscht dass auch jene leute jetzt
bestimmt dass du mich runter gehauen hat
nein ich hatte schon was also ich hab
hab mehr verloren weil ich habe schon
quanz eingesammelt richtig so das
bestimmt genau die vier konferenz
natürlich merkst du bist du wirst es
lade ich habe einfach aber ich bin so
gerne wir wir machen auf jeden fall
unser business oder kann man schon sagen
ja auf jeden fall nötig sein die wie
schaut's aus bei den 54 kannst ich gucke
jetzt aber nicht schränkt nicht nur ab
ja ich mache das auch immer irgendwie
wenn überhaupt am ende der runde aber
das schaffe ich meistens jeweiligen
nämlich auswendig kannte ich hab dich
gehört ist irgendwo in der nähe meiner
du bist ja irgendwann schwere
mitschülerin aber anders gerade irgendwo
sonst schon wieder ich habe schon wieder
simpson gehört schon wieder
es ist richtig behindert weil ich wenig
nach hinten gucken was mein gott wichtig
gejagt haben du hast mich 1000 köln
blöcke in der zeit gesammelt durch
einfach nur so versessen darauf war ich
irgendwie zu eseln leichter gefallen
das lässt aber das problem da vergisst
man selber das ist glaube ich bin so ein
problem hitler und so bin halt einfach
zu sehr wie andere leute umwegen ich
kenne das ja ich habe auch manchmal so
ich hasse wirklich spieler hebel so
direkt vor der nase in kolberg weg
machen
nach erfolgter dauer lernen
richtig wie man da lernt man gibt uns
sind live hacks live hacks vergeben
eigentlich kann man das echt super
übertragen weil wenn ihr zu sehr darauf
bedacht den anderen zu schaden vergesst
ihr euch selbst das dank max max besser
und gekommen egal ich denke mal hier und
kann ich für mich entscheiden wenn ich
jetzt nicht um unterfalle weißt du noch
beim letzten konzert der bei mir auf dem
kanal wo ich dich richtig runter ghana
alter so viele kreuz rede natürlich
kennt leute
franz ist verlinkt in der beschreibung
nach ihm vorbei checken und euch das
scrollen battle anschauen das letzte auf
seinem kanal bzw
ich will mir auch schon ausgemacht ich
bin auch wieder runter gefallen nein ich
hatte bis auf 99 metern
ich habe im kino ich sagen jetzt kein
fairplay mehr als mässig hole gerade
noch gut welche muss ich sagen dass in
der mitte oder vierter aus wer glaubt
noch immer lieber keine auskunft
ok ok ich jetzt aber zu dir naja ich hab
nämlich ein paar lagerbox kader bekommen
mit was fallen langsamkeit bei mir dreht
sich alles hier über greifen ist aber
auch erst gehört mein erster l'aquila
gehe ich eigentlich zu sammeln
ich habe die nicht nötig hat immer
wieder gesagt bekomme bekommt immer voll
und solltest du dich scheiße finde es
gut wenn du es immer bekommt aber wenn
du hast sogar etwas gutes ich hatte ganz
langsamkeit siehst du deshalb lass es
lieber weil dann kann ich den vorteil
dadurch kriegen dass ich gute kriege ja
ok alles klar
so wird eigentlich ich habe jetzt hast
du gar mehr als ich das an zahlen und
jetzt kommt meine meine wunsch karte
jetzt kannst du das kannst hier gut
spielen nö waren nur weil das die
einzige weil ich mir aussuchen durfte
deshalb wollte ich nur sagen das und
deshalb habe ich nur gesagt ist meine
wunsch platte
ich finde den staat immer so ein
bisschen rändern jaja ich mal gibt es
auf der einen seite richtig viel wo ich
immer so lang er gesagt gar nix dann
gibt's unten ein bisschen besten film so
im mittelfeld gibt's immer relativ
schnell wahlkampf richtig viel
regeneration
also ich hab einfach gerade über 100
glaube ich verloren mit einer insofern
ich hab ein paar nächten tierversuch
geschätzte drittel zu spielen ich bin
als einziger nach unten gegangen und ich
hatte 4000 konz geschafft und ja
insgesamt ich glaube wenn ich nach unten
gefallen habe ich 300 400 konzerten was
4000 zu geschafft ja ich hab's geschafft
aber es hält kein rekord war einfach
alleine in der nacht und aber zumindest
mit kumpels oder ganz einfach im
teamspeak mit zwei einander ab
ich würde schon sagen irgendwie mit
jugendlichen rennen leuten gewesen alte
gefallen
ok dann spürst du jetzt denn ich bin und
ich führe mit 3 100 coins die forschung
gemacht auf der karte aber ich glaube
diese drei mal kurz geben sich gar nicht
so viel
jetzt kommt schon mal drei angeln es ist
ich hörte nichts untertreiben jetzt
jetzt kommt halt voll krass darauf an
somit mit mitteilten soll das wird schon
wird schon heftig glaub ich ok ok
schwert ist auf jeden fall am start
auch unendlichkeit bogen instanz ich
weiß nicht ob ich nicht falsch
eingekauft habe ich kann nicht ich will
nicht spoilern aber ich bin ich bin
richtig kasse eines ob also ich als ob
markt bleibe aber einer sache nicht ganz
sicher aber ist dass es schade dass er
dass diese entscheiden so unglaublich
lange dauern bis man kriegt was man will
richtig schlimm besonders die zeit geht
richtig schnell verbreitet ja nicht aber
auch nur wenn du irgendwas cooles
brauchst perfekt so konnte ja sehr nice
hatte ich muss jetzt ich habe viel zu
billig 11 ich habe viel zu viele konter
okay man zeug haben naja also ja aber
auch gute sachen muss ich sagen also ich
muss sagen die entscheidung von der
rüstung her hätte besser sein können
also schon so weit ist jetzt ziemlich op
bei mir weil hält wasserläufer fahren so
weiter
meist haben möchte aber so hanisch helm
könnte besser sein aber der rest ist
einfach ne du wirst du gleich sehen dass
ich noch so hat ist nicht erklären was
ich hab manchmal ist es gut
ja die haben lange brand aber insgesamt
anderthalb herzensklub das könnte
richtig mache dir schaden noch ich habe
kein ich hab mich so castro touristen
hast du deine angel entscheiden und sich
nun das tun macht aufs parkett
ich lass uns spaß macht einfach nein es
geht aber nicht wenn du dich importieren
mensch ist oder bist du ja gut es kann
sein dass solange kämpfen freund
das ist immer so übels ungewiss für mich
der der kampf teil
also ich denke mir so du hast ja
eigentlich schon 2000 künstler und damit
kann man ja eigentlich nicht irgendeine
scheiße kaufen da musst du schon
irgendwann etwas krasses jetzt aus
laufwerke haben soll die so richtig
lernt man da so oder das einfach richtig
verpackt verkaufen
kurt beck ist aber ein kajakfahrer dann
aber nicht entscheidende stand drauf
festigte wasser darf keine angst selbst
vergewissern ob ich die sache ist halt
ich hab noch ultra viele herzen was
heißt so traf diese naja ich hab schon
dass zur spitze ein stück kann sich
sehen lassen aber wenig habe ich auch
nicht gerade wenig als ob es muss
kreativ sein aber gar nicht treffe es
ist so spannend mit
zum glück habe ich noch ziemlich viele
gold äpfeln zum glück ist ja ok ok hat
auf jeden fall kein wasser 3 am start
ich habe was allah verzeiht gut dass du
sagst kollege superstar
naja sieht man auch trägt am speed
unterschied ich weiß du ich ich treffe
ich die ganze zeit aber da geht wie
durch dich durch jetzt wieder nicht in
meine hacks so schlimm oder pastors
kinect nicht okay solange es ja nicht so
auffällig ist härter und battles 2 also
1 1 ganz okay weil küsst man nicht so
auffällig mit ja
sind halt nicht so viele spieler die
davon betroffen sind wir kennen uns
jetzt werde ich auf jeden fall auch in
der nächsten folge vielleicht auch mal
nix am start habe ich dann mal ein
kollege wii shop offenen herzen
ich habe auf jeden fall nach 18 stück
hey du laberst körbel aber ich habe das
gesamt ich habe insgesamt 22 herzen
ich treffe aber gut oder 22 aber wie
kannst du denn gerade im 18 haben
wer mich holt er per du musst du musst
mehr an land kommt einfach nur ins
wasser gucken die pfeile liegen so viele
hypo alter es ist hell aber schwöre dass
du achten helfen hast ja also zuschauer
nur 16 und hat nur noch vier oder sowas
aber dann würde ich aber glaube ich
nicht so offensiv zu dir kommen hier
nicht was kann alles taktik sein mag
kann ich komplett verarschen gerade und
du glaubst es mir einfach die sachen man
recht wenig übertreibt aber bisher recht
wenig jetzt gehe ich aber ganz combo ist
gibt es mit wasserläufer kübels die
combos austeilen man kräftig und der
zeit ab jetzt wieder nicht als ob schon
wieder die ganze 15 herzen
ich mache immer einen entscheidenden
fehler diesmal war es dass ich zu
schnell level gekauft hat hierzu 70
level mir gekommen
das kenne ich und hatten dann hatte ich
keinen artikel 12 gold äpfel kaufen
ich hatte einfach noch 1600 coins und
hatte ich die ganze ausrüstung gekauft
wird hat dirigent gefehlt alter leute
ist mega ätzend wenn ihr noch mal live
sehen wollte
die kommentare ich werde so lange
trainieren bis ich ihn schlagen kann
erläutert 3 0 für mich auf jeden fall
wieder etwas und dann sehen wir noch
nicht mal macht's gut und bis dahin
tschüss